[Music]
new routine what's is that probably
morning routine you guess
yeah has your morning routine changed
yeah so like this is my usher moment
it's my confession
dude my routine like collapsed i it
didn't collapse i allowed it to i
checked out of it um
in the last like several months i've
been on the road all over the country i
got a great routine when i'm on the road
but not so much when i'm at home and
then writing the book i've been working
20 hour days for
maybe a month or two it's been a it's
been a trek and so i guess confession
one is
i didn't stick to the routine
and then when i don't stick to the
routine i get unwieldy and then when i
meaning my diet goes to crap i don't
exercise this regularly and then my
writing isn't as good and that gets me
frustrated and then my work isn't as
good and that gets me frustrated and
then and then then it just has a cascade
so about two weeks ago man i locked it
back in had to really dial back up the
routine and then slowly work to our
where i am back now so
um yes i got out my pocket both have it
here i think i do maybe i put on my desk
um i still have my i still have my
little card my note card that i write
down um i do it the night before now
here's tomorrow's workout what that's
gonna be and then here's tomorrow i look
at my calendar
and see what i've got going on tomorrow
and i can just make a quick checklist
and that gets all my thoughts out of my
head
and then at night i try to make sure
that i've got my plan for the next day
before i start my going to bed routine
and then i get up man i get up pretty
early still get up about five 5 15.
and
do my coffee or my tea and then
exercise and then i got my i brought my
this is my gratitude journal that i do
almost every day
and then this one's new this year james
kelly this is my uh
i have something about y'all in here
it's my stories journal
i just have these looping
thoughts that just stay in there and
stay in there and stay in there and stay
in there and there it's called
rumination john i was about to say it's
just ruminating over and over oh my
imaginary conversations when i see kelly
next i'm gonna just tell her you better
just wait until i and i never say it
it's just a waste of my time but i start
rumening and ruining so this it or the
yeah you're the worst dad ever or
whatever so i wake up in the morning
or uh as i'm getting going through my
morning and i have this out and i'll
just rank down
um
you're the worst dad ever that's like a
thought in my head or you really screwed
it up last night when you should have
gone to bed earlier i write these
stories down and that way i can get arms
linked and i can look at them and just
say is this true or not
and if it's not true then i can just
draw a line through it and if it is true
then i can solve it and then move on
jacob calls it detachment uh michael
singer calls it mindfulness it's just
looking at my thoughts
and not letting him take over my body
and saying is this thought true and then
i can just move on from it so i had this
with me
still meditate several times a week not
as much as i should i gotta get back
into doing that um still i haven't still
exercised regularly and then man i had
to get the cold tub back out
it's so great
it's so great good people 99 bucks at
tractor supply it's just like a
bucket
fill it with water and just set it
outside it's not a bucket actually it's
like a trough fill with water and just
let the cold air do its thing this
winter and then just go sit in it three
to five minutes in the morning
it is incredible have you all ever done
that yeah i won't do that will you
i've done cold showers yeah yeah um a
lot of times i'll take a warm shower and
then
i'll turn it to cold right before i get
out just to make you angry yeah just to
start it off with a really pissy day
that's awesome i also did this um
so
i got with dr gus vickery i'm gonna have
him on the show and he's gonna go
through my my blood work and my genetic
stuff he i finally just bit the bullet
and did a full panel this guy was asking
me questions
i have a genetic trait they call the
cookie jar jean
that says you have a very difficult time
it's wired in you that when the package
is open
you're gonna eat it all
and so you can you can white knuckle it
you can willpower your way through it in
seasons that is not a strategy and so he
said just looking at your genetics the
strategy for you and let's say gummy
candy is never prevention don't have
them in your home don't have them in
your bag that's why my serial killer
wife can buy a bag of gummy candy and
just have one
one like every few days
like a
murderer she's in one of your podcasts i
bet i don't know how you can do that you
can do that but she does i can't like
he's like said that's in your jeans and
they have like a name for it anyway
it was fascinating but um got a bunch of
new supplements and stuff but it really
got back
got me back to man i gotta take care of
my diet i got to
really be intentional about exercising
every single day and i am
doing more strength training let's see
how strong i can get and now that i'm
old
and
man the the
temperatures the saunas and the cold
tubs man
i need this show to be better so we can
buy one of those fancy cold tubs things
are amazing and like uh
those saunas would be great too
i guess the cold tub would just be for
when it's not winter time and you want
to do the same thing right yeah you can
put it inside i mean i got in this
morning it was a little bit sketchy
there's some
some i mean i don't know like cody's
drinking from it or something i don't
know it wasn't probably this the most
hygienic thing in the world but it's
cool that's cool i don't know um so
that's the new routine um what i'm
focusing more on when it comes to teen
is my evening routine and my wife and i
actually had a long discussion about
this this weekend talking about
i found myself sitting in the driveway
for 10 or 15 minutes when i get home i
just sit there and i may scroll social
media i may just listen to the song on
the radio but it's almost a gearing up
for
round two like i've
gone to work and or i mean i did my
morning routine that's run one round two
is going to work and then now round
three like
okay that's back into debt
and i i don't want that she doesn't want
like i want that to be the place i can't
wait to get to because i can just go
and so we've done several things we've
set up one of which um will just be a
a routine a tradition that when i get
home we're all there when she gets home
then we're just gonna all pause for a
minute me and the little ones even if
they're in the middle of a thing where
everyone's gonna stop for a few minutes
just acknowledge each other as humans
and it may be that i need to go exercise
15 minutes and just kind of get the
shake offs maybe that we're going to
have a dance party for phoenix but it's
just something about to mark
we're all here and something i can lean
into and look forward to
um maybe having tea we all have tea
together whatever that looks like
but there's something about an evening
routine that is going to make coming
home not a
another assignment but a place of rest
and a place of um rejuvenation not a
place of
more shame and not doing great so
yeah
um so yeah that's it on the routine kind
of being lame i will say this
get a routine
mine has gotten streamlined this time
last year was really complicated it's
gotten more streamlined wake up early do
my journaling exercise do the cold
variations and make sure i'm spending
quality time with the humans in my life
um and that's about it
but get one and stick with it and if
your life begins to make your
morning routine impractical
usually it's your life that's the
challenge not your routine